we are asked to approximate the
principal root or the positive square
root of 45 to the hundredths place and
I'm assuming they don't want us to use a
calculator because that would be too
easy so let's see if we can approximate
this just with our with our pen and
paper right over here so square root of
45 so the square root of 45 or the
principal root of 45 45 is not a 45 is
not a perfect square it's definitely not
a perfect square but we know let's see
what are the perfect squares around it
we know that it is going to be less than
the next perfect square above 45 is
going to be let's see it'll be 49
because that is 7 times 7 so it's less
than the square root of 49 and it's
greater than the square root of 36 and
so the square root of 36 the principal
root of 36 I should say is 6 and the
principal root the principal root of 49
is 7 so this value right over here is
going to be between it's going to be
between 6 & 7 and if we look at it it's
only 4 away from 49 and it's 9 away it's
9 away from 36 so it looks like so the
difference between 36 and 49 is it's 13
so it's a total 13 gap between the 6
squared + 7 squared and this is this is
9 of the way through it so just as a
kind of approximation maybe and it's not
going to work out perfectly because
we're squaring it this is add a linear
relationship but it's going to be closer
to 7 then it's going to be to 6 and at
least the square or the 45 is 9 13th of
the way so we could try we could try
let's see it looks like a lot so that's
about that's about two-thirds of the way
so let's try six point seven let's try
six point seven as a guess just based on
0.7 is about two-thirds it looks like
about the same actually we could
calculate this right here if we want
actually let's do that just for fun so
913 says the decimal is going to be what
it's going to be 13 into 9 we're going
to put some decimal places right over
here
13 doesn't go into 913 does go into 90
and it goes into 90 let's see does it go
into it seven times it goes into it six
times so 6 times 3 is 6 times 3 is 18 6
times 1 is 6 plus 1 is 7 and then you
subtract you get 12 so went into it
almost exactly seven times so this value
right here is almost zero point seven
and so if you say how many times is 13
going 120 it looks like it's like nine
times yeah it would go into it 9 times 9
times 9 times 3 get rid of this 9 times
3 is 27 9 times 1 is 9 plus 2 is 11 you
have a remainder of 3 so you get it's
about point six nine so six bits so six
point seven would be a pretty good guess
this is 0.6 nine of the way between 36
and 49 so let's go roughly 0.69 of the
way between six and seven so this is
once again just relaxing it's not
necessarily give us the exact answer we
have to use that is to make it a good
initial guess and then see how well it
works so let's try let's try six point
seven let's try six point seven and the
really way to try it is to square six
point seven so the six point seven six
point seven times six point maybe don't
write the multiplication symbol there
six point seven times six point seven so
we have 7 times 7 is 49 7 times 6 is 42
plus 4 is 46 put a 0 now because we're
now and we're now moved up two we've
moved a space to the left so now we have
6 times 7 is 42 carry the 4 6 times 6 is
36 plus 4 is 40 and so 9 plus 0 is 9 6
plus 2 is 8 4 plus 0 is 4 and then we
have a 4 right over here and we have two
total numbers behind the decimal point 1
2 so this gives us 44 point eight nine
so six point seven guess it's pretty
close but we're still not it's still not
probably right to the hundred well
what's definitely not to the hundreds
place this is we've only gone to the
tenths place right over here so if we
want to get to
35 this is this 6.7 squared is still
less than the square root or I should
say 6.7 squared is still less than forty
five or six point seven is still less
than the square root of 45 so let's try
six point seven one so let's try six
point let me do this in a new color I'll
do six point seven one in pink so let's
try six point seven one increase it a
little bit see if we can go from forty
four point eight nine to forty five
because this is really close already and
if this is well let's just try it out
six point seven one so once again we
have to do some arithmetic by hand we
are assuming that they don't want us to
use a calculator here so if 1 times 1 is
1 1 times 7 is 7 1 times 6 is 6 0 here 7
times 1 is 7 7 times 7 is 49 7 times 6
is 42 plus 4 is 46 and then we have two
zeros here 6 times 1 is 6
6 times 7 is 42 this new 4 here 6 times
6 6 times 6 is 36 plus 4 is 40 plus 40
so if you really well it's interesting
to think what we got incrementally by
adding that that 100 over there because
this part over here well we'll see
actually when we add all of this up you
get a 1 7 plus 7 is 14 1 plus 6 plus 9
is 16 plus 6 is 22 2 plus 6 plus 2 is 10
and then 1 plus 4 is 5 and then we bring
down the 4 and we have 1 2 3 4 numbers
behind the Deaf 2 3 4 so when you B
squared six point seven one six point
seven one squared is equal to 45 point
zero two four one so six point seven one
is a little bit greater so let's let me
make it clear now we know that six point
seven is less than the square root of 45
and we know that that is less than six
point seven one because when we square
this we get something a little bit over
the square root of 45 but the key here
is is when we squared this
so six point seven squared so let's six
point seven squared goddess forty four
point eight nine which is 1111
hundredths away from forty five so this
is and then if we look at six point
seven one squared we're only two point
four hundredths above forty five so this
right here is closer to the square root
of forty five so if we approximate to
the hundredths place definitely want to
go with six point seven one